it looks like Xbox is about to lose
about $120 million bizly that is
basically nothing to Microsoft but to
most of us an unfathomable amount of
money this is because of the closure or
the shutdown of the OverWatch League the
OverWatch league has 20 teams and they
all recently voted to shut down the
League this happening means an
Activision Blizzard obviously now owned
by Microsoft has to be each team $6
million at least according to Windows
Central this adds up to $120 million in
total worth noting each team reportedly
paid 7.5 million to participate in the
league plus operating fees but the
OverWatch League was on decline
regardless but certainly as it turns out
a shutdown is very costly